Welcome back to the The David Pakman Show,
we've been wondering whether Republicans in
the House of Representatives and in the Senate
are ever going to denounce these outrageous
new members of Congress.
We're talking about people like Marjorie Taylor
Green, Lauren Bobert, Madison, Cawthorn, or
are Republicans going to be supportive of
these new radicals or are establishment Republicans
going to avoid talking about them altogether?
And we're going to look through two examples
today.
We have our first example, and it's a really
good one.
This is Steve Scalise.
Steve Scalise is a Republican congressman,
also the House minority whip.
And he was on Fox News yesterday morning and
he was asked about comments made by Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green and somehow he was able
to abort that question and talk about Joe
Biden, China and carbon.
It sounds like this couldn't possibly happen,
but it's exactly what happened.
Let's take a look at the video clip.
Marjorie Taylor Green, the freshman congresswoman
from Georgia, under some fire for past comments.
I'm going to be meeting with Majority Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy later.
And Liz Cheney is going to have to talk to
some of her members on the Republican side
who would like to see her removed from her
leadership position because of supporting
impeachment and voting for that.
Based on your conversations, are more of your
members supportive of Green or Cheney?
Well, first of all, I've rejected those statements
by Marjorie.
And, you know, I think we're going to be talking
tomorrow in conference.
We're going have an in-person meeting, you
know, in the Capitol where we're going to
be talking through a lot of these issues internally.
Look, first of all, we're very united in our
opposition to the devastating economic hits
that President Biden has been doing in his
first two weeks.
The Paris accord we haven't even talked about
will crush American manufacturing and send
it to China, where they emit five times more
carbon to make things like steel that Pennsylvania
will not be able to make if they get that.
So we're going to be talking about all those
things.
Steve Scalise is a horrible ideologue, but
he's also somewhat of a realist.
And he does seem to realize that Marjorie
Taylor Green is bonkers.
I mean, just cuckoo.
But he still manages to pivot on a question
about Marjorie Taylor Green and talk about
Chinese carbon and Joe Biden.
And it's just out of this world.
What do you think about Marjorie Taylor Green?
He talks about carbon and there's a difficulty
here for Republicans because until it's clear
otherwise, they have to assume that the types
of people who support Marjorie Taylor Green
are an important part of the electorate to
the Republican Party.
They have to assume until it's proven otherwise,
that a lot of the supporters and voters of
Marjorie Taylor Green are also the types of
people that people like Steve Scalise need
to continue getting support from.
And I'm not saying that Scalise would otherwise
denounce Marjorie Taylor Green, but he must
be aware of the fact that denouncing her straight
up might not play well with the portion of
the voters that he and his party need.
And in the end, failure to act is a form of
consent.
And all of these Republicans who no doubt
will fail to do a damn thing about these outrageous
radicals that got voted in during the last
election are complicit.
But they are trying to sort of thread a needle
to avoid consequences as much as possible
for the Republican Party and for themselves.
That's all they're doing.
You know, we talked earlier about Newsmax
now doesn't want anybody talking about Dominion
voting systems.
And they tried to kick off my pillow guy,
Mike Lendell, when he wanted to talk about
Dominion voting systems.
Newsmax says not all of a sudden found decided
that the truth is important.
Newsmax is not all of a sudden decided that
journal journalistic ethics matter to them.
These things are financial, pragmatic calculations.
And it's the exact same thing with with Steve
Scalise.
And case in point, the further we get from
January 6th without accountability, the more
and more that Republicans like Steve Scalise
are going to be able to just opt out of condemning
the people who were most responsible in the
Republican Party for inciting that riot, which
certainly includes Donald Trump at the top
of the party, but increasingly also includes
people like Marjorie Taylor Green and Lauren
Bobert.
You know, after the Access Hollywood tape,
some of them claimed to be outraged, but then
they weren't anymore.
And then, you know, just months ago when Kelly
Lefler was asked about that tape, she was
able to get away with saying, I don't even
know what you're talking about.
I've never seen that tape.
I don't know a thing about it.
And the the sort of last thing before we move
on to the next clip here is we've been looking
at a lot of interviews over the last few days
that Republicans have given on CNN, Fox News,
Newsmax, 018, et cetera, noticed the complete
lack of policy platform in the Republican
Party.
Right now, yeah, I know that that's been the
case for a while in some bigger picture sense,
that it's been a lot about just prevent Democrats
from doing stuff.
But right now there is a completely they're
not even pretending to care about policy.
They say Joe Biden is doing too many executive
orders.
They say, where are we going to get the money
for all of the stuff that Joe Biden wants
to do with the covid stimulus, one point nine
dollars billion package.
And they say why hasn't Joe Biden more quickly
dealt with the virus, even though he's only
been in office for two weeks?
There is they aren't even pretending to have
actual policy proposals of any kind, with
the exception of that pathetically small stimulus
package that they are proposing as an alternative
to Joe Biden's.
It's about being anti Biden, it's about being
anti Democrats.
And it's about a PR essentially at this point.
And if they had thought the virus with half
the conviction that they've been using over
the last 14 days to fight Joe Biden, we would
be much better off in this country.
We would have had far fewer covid deaths in
this country.
But sadly, that's never been their priority.
Let's now look at another example of a Republican
confronted with the comments of Marjorie Taylor
Green